wir sind aus deutschland und wir wollten
uns bedanken für das gas aus groningen
ja manche können noch darüber lachen gut
so schlimm ist es ja auch nicht ein paar
häuser stehen ja noch aber ansonsten ist
wohnungen in groningen gerade eher
schwierig aber die holländer haben halt
sicher beim vertrag
[Musik]
unterschrieben aber
die zeiten
aber warum hat man sie überhaupt auf
einem gasfeld gebaut
tja das war doch dumm oder ja das ist
und was noch viel rummel ist warum haben
wir das erst nötig wie viele erdbeben
gibt so
12 monate 12 monats
abstand
der kleinste
fehler vor wo gehobelt wird
da fallen späne
der preis dafür in und rund um groningen
gibt es 27 tausend häuser mit
erdbebenschäden bis jetzt nicht so wenig
[Musik]
das hat große einfluss für die menschen
die menschen sind ja die haben hier
gelebt und die haben hier gelebt und die
haben ja die kinder sind hier aufgezogen
ich habe auch eine schule und das wird
alles jetzt zerstört gegen die ard aber
wir lassen groningen natürlich nicht
allein die bundesregierung hat 5000
helfer in der bevölkerung verteilt naja
das ist schön aber der kleine bursche
kann nicht mehr in die schule gehen also
wir brauchen noch etwas mehr ja okay
vielleicht schaffen auch 6000 ich hab
mal was ich machen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ein vertrag nicht mehr geändert
kann worden weil es bleibt dann noch
erdbeben
gedanke ja ich kann es auf
niederländisch vertrag mit den haag
vertragen
da kann man nichts machen
kann leider nichts machen
märz nord interesting verbot
von crysis
klar dem alles nicht schön auf der
anderen seite wir haben im vertrag
machst du nichts
und 50 jahren ist ja eh alles überflutet
von daher würde ich sagen alter weiter
zurück ins studio
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
info box neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]